intermediäre schwarze löcher sind bisher
verborgen und rätselhaftes muss sie
geben aber bisher hat sie noch niemand
so wirklich gefunden größer als schwarze
löcher die aus sternen entstehen und
kleiner als supermassereiche schwarze
löcher im zentrum von galaxien an
astronomie team hat jetzt eine super
spannende entdeckung den zentrum eines
nahen kugelsternhaufens gemacht hier
haben die fachleute eine riesige
ansammlung von schwarzen löchern
aufgespürt könnte diese entdeckung
endlich dazu beitragen das rätsel um die
mysteriösen intermediäre schwarzen
löcher zu lösen klicks um sein feature
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpassen
ihn nicht los geht's herzlich willkommen
unser klick zum podcast hellt sich
weiter auf den vorderen plätzen der
science podcast sehr cool und genauso
cool waren die kommentare dazu wo ihr
überall den podcast shirt unter dem
humor videos wir sehen uns dass diese
woche an und dann gibt es diesen tollen
nano experimentierkasten frei haus und
vergesst nicht den podcast zu abonnieren
die links sind hier unter me und in der
video beschreibung und eben angebunden
kommentar die nasa hatte das mal als
kosmische detektivarbeit bezeichnet
gemeint war die suche nach den
intermediären schwarzen löchern diese
sind rund 100 bis 100000 mal schwerer
als die sonne doch das problem diese
unsichtbaren schwerkraft giganten sind
super schwer aufzuspüren und gelten so
als missing link im spektrum der
schwarzen löcher zum einen sind sie
kleiner und weniger aktiv als
supermassereiche schwarze löcher
außerdem reicht ihre anziehungskraft
nicht aus um dauerhaft sterne und
anderes material anzuziehen und so
bleibt astronomie teams nur eines
ausschau halten nach der
röntgenstrahlung die sterne ausstrahlen
wenn sie von einem solchen schwarzen
noch zerrissen werden doch bei der suche
nach denen intermediären schwarzen
löchern braucht es zudem auch eine menge
glück denn um diese aufzuspüren muss
solch ein schwarzes loch eben auf
frischer tat ertappt wird und zwar bei
seiner mahlzeit also wenn es einen stern
anzieht und dann verschlingt denn nur
dann kann man das schwarze loch bzw
die röntgenstrahlung des sterns sehen
die so genannten inter mit ihren
schwarzen löcher vermuten als promi
teams weltweit inzwischen bereich
zwischen den stellaren schwarzen löchern
und den supermassereichen schwarzen
löchern der galaxienkerne und bisher war
die suche nach solchen objekten im
prinzip erfolglos es gibt zwar
kandidaten aber definitiv belegt ist
noch kein intermediäre schwarzes loch
deswegen suchen forschungsgruppen
weltweit fieberhaft nach diesen
intermediären schwarzen löchern das muss
sie einfach geben meinen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ein französisches forschungsteam hat
sich jetzt auf die spannende suche nach
intermediären schwarzen löchern in
kugelsternhaufen gemacht dazu haben sie
einen blick in das herz eines uralt
haufens gewagt die rede ist vom kugl
sternhaufen ngc 6 397 der rund 7800
lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist die
fachleute zählen zu den sogenannten kern
kollaps sternhaufen die schwerkraft in
deren zentren ist so enorm dass sich
massereiche sterne ins innere bewegen am
ende ihres lebenszyklus kollabieren sie
dann dort im zentrum zur supernova
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
gehen davon aus dass sich hier also
sternen relikte wie weiße zwerge und
neutronensterne sammeln durch deren
verschmelzung könnten dann die
mysteriöse intermediären schwarzen
löcher entstehen so die vermutung bisher
doch die suche nach diesen speziellen
schwarzen löchern war bisher meist nicht
von erfolg gekrönt befindet sich aber
möglicherweise im kugelsternhaufen ngc 6
307 ein solcher unsichtbarer schwerkraft
gigant die aktuelle entdeckung des
französischen forschungsteams könnte
licht ins dunkle bringen ohne zweifel
schwarze löcher gehören zu den
spannendsten objekten überhaupt im
weltraum in ihnen kollabieren raum und
zeit der raum wird unendlich
zusammengestaucht wahrscheinlich nur zu
einem punkt zur singularität und die
zeit dehnt sich ebenso ins unendliche
bei den meisten schwarzen löchern die
wir bisher gefunden haben handelt es
sich um schwarze löcher die im zentrum
einer galaxie positioniert sind sie
können eine masse von einer million bis
zu 18 milliarden sonnenmassen aufweisen
ein beispiel dafür
sanitas stern im herzen der milchstraße
sie sind gleich zu finden weil wir
wissen wo sie
nämlich im zentrum von galaxien und sie
verschlingen ständig materie und
verraten sich durch die röntgenstrahlung
die dabei entsteht dann gibt es eine
weitere kategorie schwarzer löcher
stellare schwarze löcher die durch die
supernova massereicher sterne entstehen
nach meinung der fachleute kann diese
art schwarze löcher nicht mehr so als 50
oder 65 sonnenmassen aufweisen
doch eine entdeckung aus den vergangenen
jahren zeigt dass dies möglicherweise
überdacht werden muss bereits im mai
2009 10 hatten die fachleute der lyc und
mirko kollaboration ein
gravitationswellen signal aufgespürt das
die bezeichnung gw 19 05 21 bekam die
analyse offenbart dass die beiden
ausgangs schwarzen löcher mit ihrem 85
und 66 sonnenmassen deutlich schwerer
waren als alle anderen die astronomie
teams bislang mit hilfe der wirke und
leider observatorium beobachtet haben
und auch das objekt das aus der
verschmelzung dieser beiden giganten
entstanden ist ist ein rekord denn es
weiß ganze 142 sonnenmassen auf die
vermutung der wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler das erste eindeutig
nachgewiesene intermediäre schwarze loch
überhaupt und das wäre eine echte
sensation dazu der astronomen da schenkt
der an dieser studie beteiligt war aber
trotz langer suche hat man solche
intermediären schwarzen löcher von 100
bis 100 tausend sonnenmassen bislang
nicht beobachtet mit zu möglichen
aussichtsreichen kandidaten gehört unter
anderem auch ein schwarzes loch mit 428
sonnenmassen us forschungsteam hat
außerdem auch das objekt mit der
bezeichnung unten eingeblendet das ist
zu lange das kann ich nicht sagen
nochmal einmal genauer unter die lupe
genommen und zwar unter anderem mit
hilfe des weltraumteleskops hubble so
konnten beispielsweise die größe und die
nähere umgebung des objekts näher
bestimmt werden
das röntgen spektrum verriet dann auch
lage und art des objekts und somit war
klar es handelt sich keineswegs um einen
namen neutronensternen sondern um ein
schwarzes loch das im randbereich der
galaxie gall 1 liegt und zwar
höchstwahrscheinlich in einem
sternhaufen und noch mehr konnten us
vorstellen herausfinden nämlich dass
dieses schwarze loch über 50 tausend
sonnenmassen verfügt und daher zu einem
der aussichtsreichen kandidaten für eine
intermediäre schwarzes loch zählt
die beobachtungen lassen darauf
schließen dass dieses schwarze loch auf
frischer tat ertappt wurde zwar beim
zerstören eines nahen stern so wird
materie freigesetzt die um das schwarze
loch kreis und sehr stark aufgeheizt so
beschleunigt wird und genau diese aktion
führt zu der intensiven röntgenstrahlung
die es ermöglicht dass möglicherweise
intermediäre schwarze loch aufzuspüren
dazu der wissenschaftler dass die
tatsache dass dieses schwarze loch einen
stern zerreißt liefert uns starke belege
dafür dass es nicht bloß ein stellares
schwarzes loch sein kann denn noch viel
mehr ist über dieses objekt nicht
bekannt die großen fragen lauten wie
entstehen solche in der medien-
schwarzen löcher und wie entwickeln sie
sich handelt es sich bei den schwarzen
löcher in dieser masse um kosmische
ausreißer viele fragen zu intermediären
schwarzen löchern sind also noch offen
und so hatte sich auch das französische
forschungs team von der sorbonne
universität in paris genau auf diese
rätselhafte objekte konzentriert die
forschenden hatten sich den
kugelsternhaufen ngc 6 307 ausgesucht
und in seinem inneren mit hilfe des
hubble-weltraumteleskops und der
satelliten gaia nach einem möglichen
intermediären schwarzen loch gesucht und
das aus gutem grund denn solche
kugelsternhaufen werden oft auch als
kosmische methusalems bezeichnet meist
sind ihre rund 100 tausend sterne
gemeinsam in der frühzeit des universums
entstanden das innere dieser kompakten
sternhaufen ist meist besonders dicht
und gilt in der fachwelt als brutstätte
der welt nennen intermediären schwarzen
löcher die fachleute hatten dazu
zunächst die bewegung und positionen der
sterne im zentrum des kugelsternhaufens
analysiert und sich dadurch hinweise
darauf erhofft ob sich hier
möglicherweise ein solcher unsichtbarer
schwerkraft gigant versteckt hält dazu
eduardo vital der an der aktuellen
studie beteiligt war
das überraschende ergebnis wir haben
sehr starke indizien für eine
unsichtbare masse in der dichten
zentralregion des haufens gefunden aber
zu unserem erstaunen stellten wir fest
dass diese masse nicht auf einen punkt
konzentriert ist laut der analyse des
französischen forschungsteams offenbaren
die stern bewegung er eine diffuse
massen konzentration die modelle
simulation zeigen dass hier
möglicherweise ein intermediäre
schwarzes loch von 500 bis 600
sonnenmassen in frage käme die fachleute
sind aber der ansicht dass die masse
verteilt
er gegen solch ein unsichtbares
massemonster spricht die simulation
lassen demnach eher auf eine ansammlung
zahlreicher kleinerer objekte schließen
die sehr dicht sind die fachleute halten
eine kombination von neutronensterns
dlan schwarzen löchern und weißen
zwergen für möglich der großteil nämlich
58 prozent könnten schwarze löcher
ausmachen gefolgt von weißen zwergen zu
30 prozent und neutronensternen zu zwölf
prozent somit hat das forschungsteam
höchstwahrscheinlich also nicht das
gefunden was beabsichtigt war
intermediäre schwarze löcher aber auch
diese entdeckung die ansammlung stellare
schwarze löcher im zentrum eines
kugelsternhaufens ist ganz besonders
denn in der theorie wurde solch ein
rudel von schwarzen löchern zwar schon
vorhergesagt bislang aber noch nie
wirklich nachgewiesen
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam unsere
studie ist die erste beobachtung der
masse und ausdehnung einer solchen
ansammlung aus vorwiegend schwarzen
löchern in einem kern kollaps cool
steinhaufen und möglicherweise führt
diese entdeckung auch auf die spur der
intermediären schwarzen löcher denn die
aktuelle entdeckung wirft neue fragen
dazu auf wie sich solche intermediären
löcher bilden könnten der theorie
zufolge geschieht dies wenn es der jahre
schwarze löcher verschmelzen falls dies
tatsächlich im zentrum von
kugelsternhaufen passiert dann könnten
solche ereignisse bereits von astronomie
teams weltweit eingefangen werden und
zwar mit hilfe der gravitationswellen
detektoren wie lego und wirkung wir
wissen also wo wir nach ihm suchen
müssen und ihr wisst wo er den podcast
findet einfach hier draufklicken und wer
weiß wo ihr den podcast schaut man unter
das um humor video
da gibt es sehr einfallsreiche antworten
bis dann bleib dran